como muchos otros rusos artyon kotenko
diseñador gráfico de 50 años optó por el
exilio tras el inicio de la invasión
rusa ucrania y horrorizado por la guerra
llegó a la vecina finlandia hasta
alcanzar su destino final parís
y
estaba en shock por la guerra estaba
perdido no podía vivir ni respirar y el
hecho de salir aquí a la calle de ver
que otra vida es posible de ver a la
gente tocar música encontrarse
intercambiar seguir dibujando en las
paredes
eso me curó mía en ingeniería muñeco y
mira pero la realidad que que tengo
encontró al llegar a la capital francesa
no cuadraba con lo que había imaginado
pronto le quedó claro que encontrar
trabajo iba a ser muy difícil a
diferencia de lo que ocurre con los
refugiados ucranianos que la mayor parte
de europa acoge con los brazos abiertos
entiendo bien que en esta situación no
tenemos derecho a pedir nada pero eso no
va a impedir nada cada vez van a venir
más personas como yo y tenemos que
darles la oportunidad de trabajar
oficialmente y expedir visados
humanitarios se puede documentar no
habido en las semanas posteriores a la
invasión decenas de miles de rusos
abandonaron su país por miedo a las
sanciones económicas y a una posible
movilización militar triste esto es
catastrófico y hay que hacer algo de lo
contrario los rusos solo serán ilegales
los ciudadanos rusos también sufren los
efectos de lo que putin denomina como
una operación especial forzados a
participar en un conflicto que no
decidieron y objetos de prejuicios en
repetidas ocasiones